Felix: Hey, how's it going, sisters??
Uh, welcome to the most....
loved show in America
5 Weird Stuff Online (Wheel of Fortune)
*Dil-Dng!*
And, we have a guest who has the honor to be on the show today, PJ! PJ the pillow!
PJ: The pillow-face guy
Felix: Everyone remember pillow face guy, Pete?
PJ: I remember Pillow Face guy from my childhood.
I remember all the comics; all the TV shows-
Felix: Especially the anime.
That was really good
PJ: Ooh! That was very good.
What are we doing, Felix?
Felix: 5 weird stuff onliiiiiiine
PJ: Oh cool. So we're not doing some impossible game like guess the celebrity based on the fart
We're just doing something nice and simple.
Felix: I know we've done a lot of competitions PJ. I know we butt headed a lot.
Oh, yeah, I know you lost a lot
Is that how it went? Hmm...
Don't worry, but don't worry PJ. This time. It's not a competition okay may be all about having fun
PJ: Is it, you're just scared so you don't want it to be a competition. Okay? Thats cool, man, thats cool.
We'll do a- Felix: My time to shine okay, okay? Are you ready for the item number one? PJ: Hell? Yeah, hit me
Felix: I don't think you're ready for item number one. There's two items- PJ: Ooh, one each!
Felix:Which one do you want ? PJ: Which I'll -
uh, I'll take the box
Felix: I think you want this one actually. PJ: I'll take the box- Felix: if you want whats in the box.
Whats in the box?
PJ: What's in the box? I wonder.
What's in the fucking box?!
PJ: Okay, sponsered by Amazon. Felix: Oh, sorry, thats not the right one
PJ: Oh-
*laugh*
PJ: Great. Let's cut all that. *laughs*
PJ: If you think I'm gonna put on like a sailor outfit- little girl Sailor Moon outfit
Felix: You have to- PJ: Yeah, no, I'm not putting on the f- damn Sailor Moon outfit.
Felix: Oh- Wow, it looks so good. PJ: Wow this is amazing. What is it, Felix?
Felix: It's an anime school girl, but you forgot the skirt- PJ: I forgot the skirt
I mean, there's no chance that if this doesn't fit. How - okay, whatever
Okay,- nice skirt
Okay, so actually the skirt does fit, actually
Felix: The skirt fits *giggle*
PJ: How does the skirt fit?
Felix: that's so weird that I- that my outfit-
PJ: Mmm, weird, yeah...
Felix: I can't find it.
PJ: Just misplaced it. Felix: That's really strange. PJ: Uh-huh, here's me
Felix: Because usually, both of us would wear something.
PJ: Yeah usually, that would happen.
That would-
You look good. Thank you. You look really good. As you can see
This is the 2017 Sailor Moon anime leather look
PJ NO!
So what this is I thought you said this video is five weird things online.
This is, uh, perfectly normal
That's it, yeah. If you're wearing like that its definitely normal.
Yyyyyyeeeahhhhhh
What's next, Felix? Oh, I don't think you're ready for next one. I'm ready for next
I mean if this is off your Amazon, I know what Jack put on that list- next item! What's next?
Poo Head!
I didn't know you had a new product, Felix. This new merch or something? New Pewdiepie merch?
Oh yeah, no, I see what you mean, that's funny. That's real funny.
Cause it's shit.
*Ha-ha*
"Savage"
Okay, there we go. Poo head, everybody.
Okay
So, since you already have an outfit on, I think you should put it on as well.
Well, I've already got enough of an outfit.
I think, Felix, you need to...I think the people want to see...*runs out of bullshit*
Right
Is this a-oh it's a game. It's a game everybody .Oh, okay.
Let's see how many points you can get PJ.
I get to throw shit at you
On behalf of all the bros, this is for you.
Sorry, the sisters. This is all for you guys.
This hat is ridiculous.
Come on! Three points, PJ! *miss*
JEEEZUS *hits*
AHHHH!
*anime noises*
NANI?!
*rip*
AHHHHHHHHHHH
It's your turn now, okay?
Ready for this PJ?
HIT ME
Damn it!
Miss
YEAH!
That's a hit.
DAMMIT!
You hit the wall...
How many points? How many--
200 POINTS!
NEXT ITEM
What is this? A vapor gun?
It just says, like, don't eat it.
Don't eat - Oh, okay. Well...
What is this?
Its like, uh, fish eggs.
Eww
Load 'em up...
Eww--AHHH
What's it gonna-I'm interested-I don't know what this is gonna shoot, but I'm very intrigued.
AHHHHHH--I missed everything.
Its okay, thats working, its working, its working! Alright.
This is why we need Michael to clean up.
Michael!
Come clean up!
Come back from Romania!
Any last words?
I-I'm scared, 'cause like, I don't know the power either.
We should have tested--
*Rick Grimes* Lock and load, baby. *hiss*
Its not working--oh come on*click*
You ready?
Yeah, I'm ready. I'm ready!
You ready to die?
AHHHHH
Was that it?
That was it?
*disappointed* It doesn't shoot vapor.
It just shoots...little gooey balls
I was expecting like waves of vapor...
Right, right. Next item!
Next item!
Do you--Have you ever grown a poo?
Ummm...not that I'm aware of.
It's time grow a poo, everybody.
WHAT
This is...what's with all the shit-themed gifts, Felix?
Well...I thought you might...I had PJ on and I thought...
This takes 72 hours.
NANI?!
Yeah, its one of those "grow-your-own-friends."
Have you run out of friends, Felix, that you now need to grow...your own...shitty friend.
It's time to grow the poo, PJ!
Okay, how does it feel? Oh is it-It's like a rubbery kind of texture right?
Oh no, its kind of--okay.
Well they--the way they showed it was that you're supposed to put it in the toilet.
REALLY
But then I can't use the toilet for 72 hours...
Yeah--What? Who thought this would be a good idea?
NEXT ITEM!
That really is, a SHIT item, Felix.
*no regret*
What is this? This looks amazing!
The--I know. Have you ever played hot potato?
Oh for fuck's sake. Is just gonna--No...NO!
Of the 21st century?
NO! Is this gonna electrocute us?
Nahhh...
Oop, there we go. Okay, its on. Okay.
So what, we're just gonna pass it back and forth?
We're just gonna-- we're just gonna throw it, PJ.
JESUS you can't just barely touch it!
But that's the whole point of hot potato. If its a hot potato...
I don't want to touch it. Ya know...
Wha--Hey, WTF, man!
Its your game, man!
*laughs* I don't think its on...
Just presenting it...
AHHHHHHHHHHHH
OH SHIT, AHH F***!
Did it get you?
I guess that's what you need to do, you need to shake it.
Wow, what a great item, PJ. That was really fun...
Yeah...
We're going after than one thing aven oh
That's what this was all about you brought me over
It just to show your weakness we yeah electric who would have fucking saw are you ready for item number?
How's the fit isis? I'm gonna number five and a half five okay. Five Ivan all right hit your other weakness fire
Do you like to drink PJ um occasionally water empty?
This is probably the most hilarious thing of everything. Okay in my life, okay? Yeah
Feet speeds cross. Oh wow okay? So how does this house is amazing adventure one box it I'll get
Kelly a drink
Help he is holding me against my will
What did he say to you?
Don't lie to me. He's speaking like
Let's see what we got we got quite a variety here. We have oh, they're double scientist as well. Uh that's
a con man
These are grapes
Why would you want these? How do they work?
You poke the straw through it. Oh
That's not Yelling hmM. All right?
Okay, all right. I was skeptical, but that's kind of funny. That's funny right hmm
oh wow PJ with that outfit in that ak
Lexus man
Okay, next item
Yeah, just wait until you see their face man. Oh
Sorry, I'll show y'all sorry felix. Just a mighty fine party
We got one more ayat to Moorabbin, okay? All right. Well we got oh wow a child's toy
Yeah, is that what the channels come to we going back to war with his name?
What was the little boy the reviewed stuff Brian Rivalry knows what else comes to feel like toy real girl? Hey?
What's kind of you look like you could use a nope no swag excuse me?
You look like you could use a little bit of a yeah cuz I'm the hairier one attitude
What is this what happened to the whack-A-mole toy don't worry about it. I was so excited to play
Hang on give me just
the Mouse King it was
But you oh, jesus you knocked the batteries out gee the how is this for kids Felix has bought this with his own money
And as we all know he is low on money. We are going to get some enjoyment out next Adam
so the nose wax ah
All right
What?
What makes you think that this would be weird remove sealed blows hair regrow?
What how what are we going to do? What are we going to do here?
What do you think is going to happen now? You know the ten says it's painless okay, so you do the nostrils with this one
Yeah, no we are far from Ryan's toy reviews here
This is the best part of their yeah seriously throw the rest of throw the rest away. They follow that
pretty good
Now I look like a schoolgirl
The vapor gun was the only one where I sort of thought this could have
Potential and then let me down everything else
Just let me down immediately so what kind of notes max kit comes with a mess there. Hell, yeah
What was even the point of this is why I want to know she's played an impossible join us next time for
fair we stuff on land the most loved show in
America Helen P. Just coming on as a guest the rest of the world hates the show only America. Oh
Sorry, leave a like everybody if you enjoyed check out PJ and remember to smile